[Music]  [Music]  you can't solve everything with money  but you can't  you haven't changed at all excuse me i  hate tinder  what the frittata i'm in the family  business  and now you work for me boomers  let's roll is that me baby corp needs  you to drink this formula for one last  mission  you want me to be a baby again  i'm texting him  give me that block of seagulls  the boss is back baby i work alone or at  least  not with him we need to work together to  save the family business  we're going to have to face evil babies  creepy babies  don't look at me jail your babies  and ninja babies  is this some kind of a ninja boy band  huh oh my gosh oh my gosh  i'm gonna go where navigation says  turn left thank you navigation  we did it i guess we did i was talking  about me and precious  oh oh  gross